everybody been punching in they request
what a hunch he'll to come show his ice
well here I am today come skate with me
the ice guy
what's up GQ you talking to quavo honcho
right now we're on the rocks
the ice way we're gonna start with your
wrist cuz my wrist is a fool you know
saying spirit the wrist King and mr.
Gucci link get some right here from
icebox and it was free so that's why I
like that piece the most this is the
honcho bracelet this actually was a gift
given to me on my birthday in a said
hunt you own on the piece on the locker
this is a rose gold bracelet Cuban link
pave settings from Elliott did it shout
out everything from New York got to have
everything populated up and I say pave
said and I mean a dip the diamond is
real real real close together and
hugging each other so they can really
fight fumes and diamonds fight at night
and all these just Cubans I got probably
like five or six persons on each wrist
this another district just to songwriter
Rose
pavayne on the house side this one cost
a little more because of their baguettes
these right here is the honcho rings cuz
I am Lord of the Rings don't nobody got
more championships than me I'm gonna go
like this I got it from like the old
like oh dope boys from the eddies had a
they're like the One Ring all for
forehand but I wanted to move all my
fingers so that's why I got it like
individually but it turned out to look
like the Hollywood sign that was so cool
about it so I like it it is right here
got pointers what is on the on the sides
I just I forgot about them
these right here is a pave famous I
styled Cartier's these was 17,000 just a
bus down the whole frames
yeah I like everything i stuff this
right here is a four carat rose kit it's
too big for my other ear kind of like
weighted down and split my earlier so
it's in my safe I just rock it doing the
Showtime I rock - what it's too heavy
[Music]
right now this is the 2-tone padded
white and rose pave it all the way out
everybody was gonna protect the tip tip
tip this it right get you one you know
when they first dropped it costs me Amy
just watch where your rows go chocolate
Scott dweller
but gets on the whole inside big bullets
around it this was probably 70,000 this
skeleton with the baguettes this was
like a honey this was a gift from cash
from exo I'm a birthday yeah go face
Scott do a little pave it all the way up
just this one heart this right here just
the dead weight piece the original
icebox came up with this logo they did
this logo off with a og subway Sun where
did that that way come from enough which
way that way this will be from this
right here's the big boy - toots on
Cuban white and rose go big whopping
ninety five thousand y'all caught me on
a light day took us a lot of my pieces
is still at the jeweler getting cleaned
some repair because I'm jumping around
on the stage going on in the night you
know my spinning pieces right now set
that ice box it's the spinning QC piece
I think he got fifty pointers all on the
size 50 pointers all on the top and when
you spin it it don't stop spinning cuz
the ribs keep spinning take all got the
craziest piece of the game the rocket
piece and she just like a whole solar
system crazy this piece right here came
from inspired by the crash bandicoot
gang but a cool Boadicea mask and I'm a
90s baby so I do a lot of nineties [ __ ]
trippy rare got the evil twin no I'm
saying little brother got to eat between
and this one right here was about 150
they go to go forget about yoga are you
big star Wars fan
oh no
I got a whiz we went to Africa we got
these gifts to us I got the Mandela one
I got one take I've got one and I was
taking out when they gave us these and
we came to Africa and this one is my
mama name my brother real got this for
me on my birthday
and you know we all love our moments
Travis got me this because my name is
album birds in the truck and gave me
this when we drop dead you don't want to
be in the jurist over all three of us is
like this we're trying to beat each
other to the pieces I made this and then
take off made the rocket that's what
made him go get the house so he came
back with the house now we got to go his
life we can't ahi tuna in the ice guy
you got to be real creative and
different do you have any like jewelry
heroes growing up when you were younger
here yeah
coochie Busta Rhymes slickery I even
like the way Sammy Davis jr. used to run
his jury Master P shiny day you know
then they all the Houston rappers they
cute the grills
make sure you've got a big enough
bankroll put up before you go by this
year we got some put up a lot of it